you've done something where you you
might be starting a trend here you
started posting photos on the Internet
where you posed with celebrities and you
do a prom pose yes and it seems like it
could have I don't know much about this
stuff but it could have the potential to
take off like planking like what if prom
pose became the next thing well I don't
think I started it it's just I had
awkward proms when I was in school
multiple proms yeah just like not
Reese's when I went to school there was
one prom you could go to in your
province in your problem oh yeah I
thought you were just a creep going to
any prize do you go to this school sure
yeah hey hey kids your uncle Chris will
buy you beer get in my Trans Am yeah
those were good times those were good
days but yeah I don't know I just like
you know because celebrities get asked
to taking pictures all the time and I
was just like to make it fun so I I have
I have pictures with so many people
where they have agreed to take prompt
but we have someone a couple hears and
then who's next well Pharaoh
that's we gotta come back that's
exciting while and then who's this Oh
before yeah when I went to space braum
joke case I won with Sigourney Weaver to
that I didn't bring but it's great
because she's very tall yeah and so she
was the big spoon in that picture I've
noticed that you're usually the little
spoon in these oh yeah I like to be
submissive to that because I sort of
feel like they're the you know they're
the dumb that sounded weird now we got
it you like to be submitted I did yes
sir yes I do you're right yeah but yeah
I don't know I just I always liked being
the little spoon in the problem photos I
don't know why all right I'm gonna leave
it alone please no all right well I hope
it catches on yo I hope so too please
send me at Nerdist on Twitter and
Instagram send me all of your take
awkward prom pictures and send them to
me wasn't that a great clip subscribe to
my youtube channel for an endless supply
of me
[Laughter]